maintenant une autre entreprise rayonne
grâce à la victoire de laurent dubernais
tardif il s'agit d movie qui a développé
la jeune ou graphie technologie
permettant de mieux diagnostiquer les
causes des douleurs au genou
ce nouvel outil est à aider le ronde
ouverte interdit à se remettre de ses
blessures blessure au genou michel
laflamme et fondatrice et pdg d movie
bonsoir bonsoir
parlez nous un peu de cette technologie
de cette jeune ou graphique a été très
utile pour le rendre vernis tardif la
géographie à 7,1 en fait c'est une
approche médicale qui complète la
radiographie et la résonance magnétique
la radiographie et les statiques la
résonance aussi et les statiques
on donne des informations qui ne sont
pas en mouvement tandis que la douleur
quand elle se passer dans notre
mouvement
donc la géographie permet d'aller
chercher cette information-là donc la
biomécanique articulaires qui explique
pourquoi ça fait mal qui quoi faire plus
pour le patient pour mieux traiter et
donc c'est un outil que vous avez
développé qui permet de voir cela
exactement c'est un outil qu'on vient
fixer sur le genou qui vient camper sur
les os ensuite c'est une information par
captage optique
ces traités par intelligence
artificielle il ya des signaux qui sont
créés un peu comme les êtres 15 grammes
c'est un signal qui vient vraiment kir
qui représente exactement la fonction
séculaire et ça c'est coralie exactement
aux facteurs mécaniques qui sont en
fonction des critères chez le patient
est donc le rang du vernis tardif a
utilisé ce produit là est maintenant
rendu votre image de marque même oui
c'est notre ambassadeur on est
privilégié très content lorem de ne voir
l'année dernière ça faisait deux ans
qu'il a mal au genou
c'est certain que dans son sport c'est
très important d'avoir des genoux en
santé et puis ça faisait deux ans depuis
sa première blessure qui traînait une
douleur persistante puis de leur accès
aux meilleurs médecins aux meilleurs
physiothérapeute
c'est vraiment la preuve que
actuellement traité d trouver la cause
des douleurs c'est difficile ça ce fait
les yeux ça c'est que l'expérience
alors que la jeune graphie d'un outil
supplémentaire aux médecins et aux
physiothérapeutes je vais avoir eu son
problème à lui oui exactement
c'était vraiment un problème qui était
même assez
pour l'appareil l'instrument qui est
assez facile mais à l'onu c'est pas
perceptible et puis on le donnait quatre
exercices très simples
tellement simple que pour quelqu'un
comme lui qui s'entraîne avec des
explosifs est complexe
c'était peut-être un peu gênant
travailler ça avec d'autres colosse de
dans la danse gym mais quatre petits
exercices très simples avec une orthèse
qui étaient un peu différentes pour
régler son problème qui étaient réglées
rapidement laurent quatre semaines et
vous vous développez ça donc depuis 2008
oui donc depuis 2008 vous développez
cela pour le ventre exactement
et est ce que vous le vendez est-ce que
les gens se procurent exactement on a
maintenant plus que 45 usagers des
cliniques médicales aude et une décrue
thérapie qui ont la géographie qu'ils
offrent à leurs patients on a des
milliers de passants qui sont faits et
puis à travers sept pays
maintenant on a en effet un financement
l'année passée dont avec investissement
québec
et puis qui nous a permis de vraiment
lancer la commercialisation à plein
régime
donc depuis deux ans en fait de planer
passées ont vu une croissance accélérée
vous développer d'autres types d'outils
on développe actuellement on est en
train de repenser à l'épaule et le bas
du dos mais on se concentre beaucoup
maintenance ont déployé cette
technologie le la rend disponible aux
patients déjà au québec il ya une
vingtaine de cliniques qu'il offre aux
patients c'est encore d'un milieu privé
mais on travaille très fort avec le
gouvernement du québec qui nous appuient
depuis le début pour le rendre
accessible dans le système de santé
publique c'est fabriqué au québec et
tout est fabriqué au québec
effectivement son fait une pièce qu on
ne peut pas activement faire encore au
québec mais qu'on essaie de trouver une
solution pourquoi c'est important de
tous fabriqués au québec mais les
valeurs les valeurs de la compagnie
movie c'est un peu aussi les valeurs de
laurence c'est ce qui nous a beaucoup
rejoint de collaborer avec lui c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille extrêmement fort
c'est quelqu'un qui qui croient dans
l'entrepreneuriat d'une famille
d'entrepreneurs
c'est quelqu'un qui a une vision ici
voir ce qui s'en va puis la famille la
loyauté il est important puis maurice
est exactement ça donc c'était vraiment
une belle collaboration qui nous rejoint
beaucoup sur cet aspect là puis de
respecter le local ici c'est important
alors au nom des genoux de laurent
duverne interdit fond vous dis merci
le président outil très intéressant mais
je pense que ce soir on voulait montrer
vraiment deux entreprises sont qui pour
qu'il ya des répercussions intéressantes
de football merci beaucoup madame la
planche merci à vous bien